Los komm mit, wir steigen ein ins Podcast UFO, hast du heute schon gelacht, Podcast UFO, steig mit ein, wir heben ab, Podcast UFO, man hätte das gedacht, Podcast UFO, komm steig ein und wir heben ab. Yeah, let's rock und herzlich willkommen bei einer neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO. Hier sind sie, Stefan und Florentin. Das hat mich sehr an meine Bandzeit erinnert. Ich glaube, das sollte ein Hommage auch sein. Clearly AI. Das war die Alex AI, die mehrere Millionen Stunden von Alex aufgenommen hat und ihn unverkennbar wieder ausgespuckt hat. Alex Sechs. Alex Sechs. Alex Sechs ist mit dabei. Und ich glaube, das sollte auch ein Hommage an Binky Sack Bu sein, glaube ich. Deine alte Band, die mittlerweile ja in der Versenkung verschwunden ist. Verschieden. Verschieden, in verschiedene Länder auch ausgereist. Man hört immer mal wieder aus verschiedenen Ecken der Welt, Kolumbien da, Peru. Ja genau, also in Kolumbien wurde ich ein paar Mal erkannt. Das hätte ich nicht gedacht, ich dachte erst wegen meiner Werbung. Ich habe ja zwischenzeitlich so massriegeleske Sachen beworben. Da war ich gross in Kolumbien plakatiert. ich glaube bei bei Binky's Act Bus war ja so, ihr habt ja wirklich hunderttausend CDs brennen lassen und davon vierzehn verkauft. Genau. Und dann den Rest verschenkt, achtzehn. Und dann den Rest entsorgen lassen. Und man weiss ja tatsächlich nicht, was passiert mit diesen CDs, die wurden tatsächlich all nach Kolumbien verfrachtet auf eine Müllhalde und dort von Müllkindern, die im Müll leben, dann tatsächlich gefunden und sehr, sehr für gut befunden. Und da ist eine richtige Binky-Sack-Boo. Genau, da ist ein bisschen Hype entstanden. Und wenn wir Touren würden, weil wir uns alle sehr doll zerstritten haben, nicht mehr machen werden, wäre die Kolumbien- und Peru-Tour definitiv ausverkauft. Ihr erkennt daran, das sind immer noch Ziele, wo ich gerne hinfahre, um dann in meiner Freizeit noch in den Menschen zu baden. Aber ich habe mir das noch auch gedacht, weil es gibt ja so viel Trash auf der Welt.
Du meinst musikalischen Trash oder Müll? Nein, einfach so Müll.
So komischen, Stichwort Gift-Shops, so Freizeitpark-Merch oder sowas, Plüsch, so Kirmes-GewKram, dann aber auch so Silvester-Zeugs, also es gibt so viele Kram. So Automaten, wo man so 50 Cent reinsteckt und es kommt irgendwie so ein unförmiges Plastikkrokodil, wo die Augen falsch aufbemalt sind und denkt sich, was ist das, wo kommt das her, also wer ist stolz darauf, was macht man damit? Kommt das in die Deko-Ecke, kommt das in die Spiegelzeugkiste? Ich muss ja tatsächlich zugeben, dass ich durchaus auch ein Liebhaber des Überraschungsei bin. Aber jetzt, um ehrlich zu sein, nicht immer einen Verwendungszweck für die besagte Überraschung habe. Denn was ich am Überraschungsei liebe, ist der nicht überraschende Teil. Die Milchschokolade, das Ei. Was außen ist. Genau. Ich mag das Äussere, das Vorhersehbare, ich mag das vorhersehbare Ei. Das ist für mich der reizvolle Teil. Das wäre doch mal spannend, für ein Überraschungsei, für Leute, die keine Überraschungen lieben, was nur aus Ei besteht, aber das jetzt habe ich natürlich logistische Fragezeichen, weil das ist bruchhaft, Bruchstückangst, jetzt habe ich eine Bruchangst, weil die kann man ja nicht in Lagern, ohne dass sie eingedutscht werden, weisst du, was ich meine? Überraschungseier? Ja, also die, die für Nicht-Überraschung sorgen, für Leute, die keine Überraschung bücken. Du meinst, Überraschung gibt dem der Schokohülle Kraft und Stütze? Ja. Ich glaube nicht, dass das, ich weiss nicht, wie die Statik eines handelsüblichen Überraschungseis aussieht, aber ich glaube, es ist nicht. Du hast schon recht, es ist deutlich grösser das Ei als das kleinere, andersförmige Ei. Es ist keine tragende Überraschung. Ich glaube, es ist eine Überraschung, die man verlustfrei entfernen kann. Warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, halt, stopp, halt, alle halten mal kurz inne. Ist das innere Gelb wegen Eigelb? Oh, was? Das habe ich noch nie geschlägt. Das habe ich wirklich noch nicht geschlägt. Was? Ist das Innere eines … Und das Äussere ist weiss wegen Eiweiss. Ist denn nicht weiss? Naja, von innen schon. Naja, von innen schon. Für die Überraschung von innen, die nach aussen guckt, ergibt es total Sinn. Das denkt, ich bin hundert Prozent in einem Ei. Ja. Von aussen hast du die Illusion, natürlich durchschauert. Naja, gibt auch braune Eier. Oh, nee, aber ist das Innere gelb? Ich dachte immer, es wäre so Warn-mä. Ich dachte auch Waren, dass man das nicht im Schling rauscht. Aber Warenfarbe Rot. Na, aber was Lebensmittel angeht nicht. Ist Warenfarbe Gelb? Ich glaube, Lila ist da Warenfarbe. Warenfarbe. Ich glaube, aber da kommst du einfach rein. Aber es gibt ja genug Leute, die ja die Überraschungseier auch öffnen können, um die Überraschung zu entfernen. Also da habe ich schon oft gesehen, man sagt ja früher, in jedem siebten Ei, und dann war es bei uns in der Schule üblich, die wirklich mit chirurgischer Präzision noch im Supermarkt zu öffnen, die Überraschung zu entfernen und dann wieder zurückzulegen. Und dann viel Spaß an das Kind, das dieses hohle Ei bekommt, und das hat man aber eine richtige Überraschung. Ist das nicht die eigentliche Überraschung? Das finde ich die eigentliche Überraschung. Ist das Ausbleiben der Überraschung nicht die eigentliche Überraschung? Wenn die Überraschung quasi im Mainstream angekommen ist oder erwartbar ist. Wenn die Überraschung, wird ja beim Überraschungsei mitverkauft. Schrengenommen ist das alles eine Lügengeschichte, weil du halt beim Überraschungsei Überraschung draufschreibst. Wenn es heißt Ei und dann ist da ein gelbes Spielzeug drin, das ist ein Überraschungsei. Dann ist so, what the? Aber wenn du Überraschungsei überraschend draufstehst, ist kein Überraschungsei mehr. Du müsstest eigentlich in so ein ganz harmloses Produkt, irgendwie so diese Schoko-Katzen-Zungen oder so, wo du denkst, okay, ich krieg hier einfach 24 Schoko-Katzen-Zungen und dann ist das durch. Genau. Ist eine sehr vorhersehbare Sache. Und dann macht die Gesellschaft daraus das Überraschungseffekt. Da ist plötzlich eine Überraschung drin, das ist wirklich eine Überraschung. Ja, ja, ja, absolut. Aber es ist wie, als hätte sich das einen eigenen Spitznamen gegeben, weißt du? Ja, ja, das stimmt schon. Unangenehm. Ne, aber was ich meinte ist, auch wir haben ja ganz viel Merch. So, das ist ja auch Trash. Wir haben viel Merch, aber eine Grossteil des Merch liegt auch auf dem Meeresboden. Das stimmt, der Suez-Kanal muss man sagen. Wo tatsächlich das nächste Mal, wenn irgend so ein Privat-U-Boot implodiert und die Kameraaufnahmen erscheinen, dann sieht man unten auf dem Meeresboden ganz viel von unserem Merch und leider stehen wir wieder PR-technisch im schlechten Licht. Also genau, wir alle erinnern uns an, der Suezkanal war verstopft, ein grosser schwarzer Rustanker verstopft den Suezkanal und da war er dann so ganz gross drauf, wie damals bei diesem Evergreen, dieses Schiff, wo ganz grob Evergreen stand, was den Suezkanal oder was war es für ein Kanal damals, verstopft hat. Und jetzt war halt unser Riesentanker das Podcast UFO 4. Ja, und wenn man mal hinschaut, was verstopft eigentlich genau den Kanal, man supt dahin, warum ist das Schiff eigentlich genau an der Küste angekommen, sehen wir genau unsere t-shirts unser community merch drop einfach wirklich genau da drin deswegen hat das leider bei vielen sehr lange gedauert weil die erst noch mal vom boden mit tauchern geborgen werden mussten die haben teilweise ein bisschen den algengeruch genau da sind auch verschiedene also ich glaube vier fünf taucher ums leben gekommen korrekt genau und familien die haben wir entschädigt, weil die haben dann ein Shirt umsonst bekommen.
Und als die Leichen geborgen wurden, haben die auch die T-Shirts getragen. Sie haben sich wahrscheinlich verheddert und sind deswegen ertrunken in den T-Shirts, weil die teilweise auch ein bisschen klein ausgefallen sind, was ein anderes, ganz anderes Problem ist. Aber das Problem ist davor gelagert.
Das ist auch ein Problem.
Aber das ist ein anderes Problem.
Ich für meinen Teil freue mich aufs nächste Jahr, weil ich brauche in diesem Jahr kein
Bild mehr irgendwo, wo so eine Das Problem ist davor gelagert. Das ist auch ein Problem. Aber das ist ein anderes Problem. Ich für meinen Teil freue mich aufs nächste Jahr, weil ich brauche in diesem Jahr kein
Bild mehr irgendwo, wo so eine Taube, die so halb in Öl und halb in so einem Podcast-Ufo-Shirt,
so eine Möwe, die dann so ein Podcast-Ufo oder so ein Delfin, wo dann so Stoffreste kleben,
wo offensichtlich ein UFO zu sehen ist. Wo dann so die Notretter holen raus, was war denn jetzt im Luftloch gestopft und es war unsere Tasse. Das sind immer unsere Sachen, das ist halt das Problem. Deswegen meine ich, wir tragen uns sowas bei, aber meine, also das läuft ja. Konsum tötet, ja, letzten Endes Konsum tötet. Meine Theorie ist nur, und das ist ein bisschen, also folgt mir, aber ich möchte von vornherein sagen, so die Richtung, die ich jetzt einschlage, ist nicht so schön, mag ich selber nicht so gern. Aber meine Theorie ist, dass welche Shirts werden am ehesten in die Altkleidersammlung gegeben? Merch-Shirts. Ja, weil man abfällt, weil der Star in Ungnade gefallen ist.
Niemand kauft Merch, weil er das ... Also, ne, 10%-Regel.
Und 5% Rabatt im Club.
Ja, anderes Thema.
Also, niemand, wie gesagt, Sternchen, niemand kauft Merch, weil er das schön findet, sondern man unterstützt, sondern man will a, zeigen, ich unterstütze diesen Künstler, die Künstlerin, also man will das repräsentieren, weil man es cool findet, nach aussen tragen, oder man will die Leute unterstützen, die das Projekt machen. Man will Kiss unterstützen mit einem Shirt von der Band. So, diese beiden Sachen. Oder man möchte wie ich sich nicht eingestehen, dass man keinen Modegeschmack hat und deswegen sich modisch komplett nur über die Dinge identifiziert, die man mag. Die man sonst mag. Damit Leute sagen, ah, okay, das ist ein hässliches T-Shirt, aber er hat es ja gekauft, weil er ist Game of Thrones Fan. Boah, spannend. Ein Part of the Night's Watch. Ah, würdest du sagen, das ist ein guter Modegeschmack? Nein, oder? Nein, überhaupt nicht. Ich hasse Mode, ich gehe nicht gerne einkaufen, deswegen bin ich immer froh, wenn ich irgendwo einen Merchartikel kaufen kann, damit ich einfach sagen kann, unabhängig davon, wie es aussieht, ist es zumindest durch meine Liebe zum Produkt gekennzeichnet. Weißt du, was ich spannend finde, aber du würdest sagen, dass du einen guten Film- und Seriengeschmack hast. Ich glaube schon, doch ich glaube schon, eher, weil du dich ausgernest, du bist jetzt bescheiden. Aber du würdest natürlich eher sagen, du hast einen guten Seriengeschmack, als dass du einen guten Modegeschmack hast. Entscheide selbst, entscheide selbst immer einen Merch. Nee, ich mein, du trägst, weil du einen guten Musikgeschmack hast, trägst du gerne Musikmerch wahrscheinlich. Ja. Allen bei denen... Nee, das ist mir zu intim. Musik ist intimer als Film. Zu fragen, was ist dein Lieblingsfilm, kannst du jemanden auf einer Party fragen. Was ist dein Lieblingsalbum, welche Musik hörst du gerade, ist, finde ich intimer.
Musik ist intimer als Filmserien. Was ist dein Lieblingsporno? So, das kann man beschreiben. Ja, das ist nicht intim. Auf jeden Fall. Aber interessanterweise habe ich heute, um beide Themen zusammenzubringen, im Supermarkt stand hinter mir ein älterer Mann mit einem T-Shirt, auf dem Gross Columbia draufstand. Ah.
Und ich fand das so lustig, weil man kennt ja diese Columbia-T-Shirts, aber er hatte so ein Columbia-T-Shirt, einfach Kolumbien. Und er war einfach Fan, aber Kolumbien, einfach represent. Und da denke ich mir auch so, was sagt man aus über sich in einem Edeka um die Ecke, wo man wohnt, mit dem Columbia-T-Shirt? Ja, na ja, gut. Hab in die Altkleider damit. Erst vor wenigen Tagen das Copa de America-Finale, und da ist Colombia im Finale gewesen, gegen Argentina hat er verloren. In welch, was ist das für eine Sportart? Fussball. Fussball. Das war quasi die EM für Südamerika und Nordamerika. Die SM. Copa de America. Copa de America. Aha. Und Argentina hat gewonnen gegen Colombia. Ah, okay. Und es sind immer die gleichen im Finale, weil es nur zwei Länder gibtänder gibt. Ich hatte nur Argentinien, da hätte ich eine Chance. Nee, weil du sagst, welche T-Shirts gehen da meist in die Ackler. Ich hätte jetzt gesagt, gar viele T-Shirts. String genommen Merch, würde ich drunter fassen. Nee. Ja, okay. Alles klar. Weißt du, du hast alles daran sagt, dass du so eine starke Meinung hast. Und ich nicht die Energie noch die Lust als Gegensargumentier. Ich strecke die Waffen, ich lege mich auf den Rücken, ich nehme meinen König und lege ihn auf die Seite und sage, okay. Für mich ist das T-Shirt nicht unbedingt ein Merch, aber popkulturelle, ich meine, ne, will ich nicht sagen. Lizenziert, ist lizenziertes Merch, die verdienen daran. Am Ende weiss man nicht. Es gibt ja auch viele im Schwarzmarkt. Genau, aber wo du wolltest mit dem Garfield. Genau, also meine Theorie ist, Merch landet zuerst alt, deine Theorie ist, Garfield-Shirts landen zuerst. Ja, hauptsächlich. Okay, würde ich zusammenfassen, finde ich okay. Jetzt habe ich nur das Problem damit, weil du willst mir auch recht geben, Merch-Shirts landen oft da, verwascht ja auch schnell irgendwie dieser Druck und so. Ja, ja, sehr oft minderwertige Qualität, 100% günstiger im Klub. Jetzt gehen diese super leicht, weiss ich nicht, ausgeblichenen, bunten, kaputten Shirts, gehen in die Altkleidersammlung. Die kommen jetzt in Länder, wo Leute Kleidung brauchen, benötigen. Die laufen dann jetzt mit, und das ist das Problem, und ich finde es ein bisschen ironisch, lustig, weil ich falsche Wort, aber da laufen dann Leute rum mit einem Gemischtes Hack- Hackshirt, zum Beispiel in Uganda.
Ja, ja. Und sind halt als Kindersoldaten unterwegs, nicht im Namen von Felix Lubrecht, aber schon als eine Art Repräsentant. Ich sag dir, das sind die ersten Shirts, die da landen. Da ist ja die Ironie der Geschichte, es gab ja mal diese Geschichte von einem Coney, dieser Warlord, wo eine riesige Kampagne gestartet wurde von einem Typen, der sagt, dieser Warlord muss aufhören, Warlord zu sein, der braucht ein neues Hobby, war ein Riesending, wirklich mit Promis und allem, riesige Kampagne. Dann hat der Typ öffentlich masturbiert, die komplette Kampagne ist in sich zusammengefallen, niemand wollte mehr was mit diesem Coney-Ding zu tun haben, alle haben ihr Coney-auft haben um den zweck zu unterstützen die eikleidersammlung gegeben die eikleider ist nach afrika gegangen und dann haben die kindersoldaten die für coney gemordet haben hatten dann cony shirts an und das ist dann schon wo man merkt so ein Kreislauf Wär es leider ein bisschen blöd gelaufen. It's the circle of life. Ja. Ist ein bisschen blöd gelaufen, aber man hat es ja mal probiert. Da kann man... Da kann man jetzt nicht... Ja, es kann man leider nicht... Aber man kann da auslernen. Man kann da auslernen. Ja, ja, voll. Das ist wirklich... Also ich habe ja... Also du kannst ja... Also nichts mehr in die Alltagersammlung geben oder was jetzt... Nee, ich sage, du kannst öffentlich masturbieren, aber mach mach das doch erst nachdem dein Zweck abgeschlossen ist. So, dann kannst du ja machen, was du willst. Ich hab letztens ein Ehepaar streiten sehen am Altkleider. Ah, ich hatte öffentlich masturbieren sehen und war ganz roh. Ich weiß nicht, wie die Szene angefangen hat. Ich bin erst mittendrin. Und oft willst du ja bei so Gesprächen von Fremden, wenn du da reingehst, sagen, ich habe die erste Hälfte verpasst, können die nochmal von vorne anfangen? Weil ich weiß gar nicht, worüber sie jetzt reden. Und die waren wirklich so, hä, ja, wie das hast du jetzt weggeschmissen? Ja, du hast doch gesagt, die sollst wegschmeissen. Nee, aber ich meinte ja nicht in Müll, dann sagt doch nicht wegschmeissen. Und dann haben die anscheinend am Altkleiderdepot gemerkt, dass irgendwas, wasgeben wollten schon weggeschmissen und der mann dann meinte auch so naja aber wir schmeissen doch eh hier rein und die frau so das ist doch was ganz anderes und es ist so ich kann beide positionen verstehen das ist eine gute szene so ich kann ihn verstehen der sagt wegwerfen ist eins unter altkleider aber ich kann auch sie verstehen die sagt nein will es gerade nicht wegwerfen, ich fand es toll, ich fand es einen tollen Dialog, ich hätte gern noch ein bisschen früher gekommen. Ich mache da nochmal eine grosse Runde und gucke, ob die zur fallenden Stunde nochmal anfangen, aber habe leider nicht mitbekommen, wo es ging. Da ist in meinem Bekanntenkreis gerade etwas Spannendes passiert, geht ein bisschen in die gleiche Richtung, und zwar fuhr sie mit ihrem neuen Lastenrad Ehrenfeld. Man merkt auch, dass Stefan mittlerweile einen anderen Freundeskreis hat, als seine Binkisack-Buraudis. Nee, aber das wird noch wichtig. Mit ihrem Lastenrad durch einen Kölner Stadtteil. Und dann liegen, dann sind da so Holztische aufgebaut, wo Kleidung draufliegen, zum Beispiel, Kleidung draufliegt.
Und da hat diese Person einen wunderschönen Pulli gefunden. Irgendwie so, sie dachte, ach krass, das ist so ein Secondhand, irgendwie so Flohmarkt mässig, ah geil, und da war so ein richtig schöner Pulli. Und dann wollte sie den kaufen und dann hat die Verkäuferin gesagt, nee, den können Sie einfach mitnehmen, hat die in die Hand gedrückt mit so einem netten Blick.
Turns out war ein Sozialkaufhaus, was Dinge verschenkt an Bedürftige.
Sie ist dann, hat das in dem Moment gemerkt, wo es ihr geschenkt wurde und musste dann zu ihrem Lasten, zu ihrem 5000 Euro.
Elektro-Lastenrad, 60 PS. Was mit nem Wuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh-Wuh- was natürlich eine sehr unangenehme Situation ist. Ja. Und jetzt hat sie sich überlegt, sie möchte jetzt, hat zu Hause bei sich Klamotten aussortiert und möchte sie jetzt da schenken, um das wieder gut zu machen, diesen Faux-Pa. Den Pulli nicht, den will sie behalten. Ja, klar. Aber jetzt habe ich gesagt, ja, also du musst ja aufpassen, dass da nicht gleiche Person da ist. Und sie hat gesagt, nee, mir ist wichtig, dass genau die Person da ist und sieht, dass sie das quasi wieder gut macht. Dann habe ich gesagt, ja, aber dann sieht sie ja, dass du den Pulli nicht zurückbringst, den du, dann hast du quasi geklaut. Dass du eigentlich gar nicht bedürftig bist. Und du beweist, dass du nicht bedürftig bist, was streng genommen das Lastenrad schon bewiesen hat, ein bisschen. Ja, ja. Alles an ihr eigentlich. Du meinst, es gibt keine bedürftigen Menschen mit Lastenrad. Du sagst, dasenrad ist das erste was man verkaufen würde wenn die armut abdriftet noch viel zu jung die werden lastenräder an sich das phänomen lastenrad ist noch so jung das ist wahrscheinlich der gebrauchtmarkt ist ja dann weil sie verkauft sind zwei jahre altes lastenrad oder sowas kann man noch kriegt man noch gut weg aber ich glaube nicht das ist der ultimative Beweis, dass jemand nicht bedürftig ist. Okay. Ja, schwierig. Aber das war eine gute Situation, wo man viel zu spät merkt, fuck. Aber es war, Moment, es war ein soziales Kaufhaus, die normalerweise Sachen billig an bedürftige Menschen verkauft, aber die jetzt aussortiert und verschenkt haben. Aber ist das jetzt nicht wieder Minus und Minus ist Plus, dass du jetzt beim Aussortieren nicht mehr bedürftig sein musst, um das in Anspruch zu nehmen? Weil die wollen es ja einfach nur loswerden, um … Nochmal, nochmal, nochmal. Explain to me like I'm five. Explain it like I'm five. Die verkaufen das ja billig an bedürftige Menschen. Die verkaufen das billig an bedürftige Menschen normalerweise. Genau, aber jetzt sagen sie, alles muss raus, wir verschenken es. Genau. Da muss man dann ja nicht mehr unbedingt bedürftig sein, dann kann es ja jeder mitnehmen. Ich finde schon, moralisch sollte man fucking bedürftig sein, sogar die Bedürftigsten der Bedürftigen, weil es ja verschenkt wird. Das ist ja die eine Situation, wo selbst die Bedürftigsten der Bedürftigen sich was nehmen können. Die wollen das ja loswerden, deswegen verschenken sie es ja, das ist ja was anderes. Nee, oder das sind so Tage, so spezielle Tage, wo wirklich dann jeder mal was nehmen kann, selbst die, die gar kein Geld haben, sich selbst, weiss ich, ganz günstige Sachen zu kaufen. Ich finde, man sollte als Lastenradfahrerin die fucking Hände von lassen. Ja, das sowieso, das sowieso. Da ist genug Last da, einfach so. Wie viel Last kann ein Mensch eigentlich haben, dass er sagt, wohin mit meiner Last? Ich brauche ein komplettes Lastenrad einfach. Das ist so ein Negativvortrag. Ja, dann kommt das Kind ins Lastenrad und dann viel Spaß später mit der Therapie, mit der Therapiekost des Kindes. Komm, Janett, geh rein ins Lastenrad, du bist eine Last für Mama, ins Ballastrad. Das ist übrigens ein kleiner Hint an die Lebensmittelindustrie, Ballaststoffe, habe ich ja gelernt, sind was Gutes, das Wort ist irreführend. Ist da die Haribo-Industrie dahinter, die das aktiv so benannt hat, dass es schlecht klingt, damit die sagen, das hat ja vollkommen Rot, hat Ballaststoffe, will ich nicht, ich will lieber Frupp? Ja, und noch was dazu, Kohlenhydrate klingt so, als wäre es sehr gesund. Ehrlich gesagt, stay hydrated. Wegen Hydro. Ja, Hydrat, also Hydrat klingt jetzt nicht. Aber Kohle, also ist es nicht so, beim Nikolaus kriegen die bösen Kinder Kohle und die guten kriegen Geschenk? Ich finde Kohle klingt nach Energie, klingt nach Kohldampf. Kohle, Wasser ist eigentlich eine Dampfmaschine. Kohlenhydrate ist eigentlich eine Mini-Dampfmaschine. Ja, boah, das treibt mich nochmal richtig an. Aber Ballaststoffe, nein, nein, nein, ich will nicht ballastet werden. Ja, ja, ja. Ich habe jetzt wieder angefangen, Pizza zu backen. Da musst du ja viel mit Mehl hantieren. Meine Herren, ist Pizza backen schwer. Ich habe wirklich, also das nochmal Respekt an jeden Pizzabäcker da draußen. Es ist unfassbar schwer, weil dieser Teig muss so dünn sein und dann musst du ihn ja transportieren. Und dann musst du ja da Mehl drunter packen und dann packst du das Mehl ja in den Ofen. Dann nimmst du die Pizza aber raus, dann ist das Mehl noch drin, das verbrennt dann. Was passiert mit dem Mehlbrand? Naja, dann kommt die nächste Pizza auf das verbrannte Mehl drauf und ich denke mir so, diese Logistik so, vergiss mal den Käse. Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, das Thema, wenn ich jetzt nicht nochmal anfange, vergiss mal den Käse. Da hast du sehr viel Hate bekommen, aber auch weggingoriert, das ganze Thema Pizza, Käse.
Ne, ich habe viel Zuspruch bekommen tatsächlich.
Okay, bei mir, ich habe auch viel Zuspruch bekommen.
Vielleicht sollen wir diese Parteien mal gegeneinander antreten lassen.
Also, wir hatten vor ein paar Folgen die grosse Diskussion, weil Flo und Thien hat das anhand des Beispiels Pizza Hawaii festgemacht.
Hawaii, ja, die grosse, das ist gut, das Triptychon aus Ananas, Käse und Krebs. Schinken. Krebs. Krebs. Krebs erregend. Richtig, im Milieu der saftigen Ananas ergebt Käse. Die Aminosäuren des Schinkens zu purem Krebs geformt. Aminosäure klingt, finde ich, nämlich, also alles ist falsch genannt. Es ist auch schlecht. Wie gesagt, also, und du hast gesagt, da geht kein Käse drauf, aber dann ist der Begriff Pizza irreführend, weil da ist ja per se schon immer Käse drauf. Ist nicht, und Käse drauf auch nicht immer Tomate. Dein Begriff von Käse, von Pizza wurde debunkt. Nein, ich möchte mich da nicht weiter darauf einlassen, weil ihr offensichtlich Unrecht habt und Pizza, wenn du irgendwo anrufst und eine Pizza bestellst, kriegst du Tomate, Käse, Teig, fertig und ich könnte wirklich locker eine Stunde über das Thema reden, weil da einige Kommentare kamen, die mich auch wirklich genervt haben, wo wirklich dann auch einer kommentiert wird, da wird dann irgendwie über die Semantik gesprochen, weil Florentin nicht, da Sprache nur durch die Verwendung definiert wird, Horst Lichtemann würde sich im Grab umdrehen, der berühmte Sprachwissenschaftler. Endesfälle. Wo ich denke, nein, stopp, es ging in der Diskussion niemals darum, ob es objektiv korrekte Worte, Bezeichnungen für irgendwas, nein, darum geht es nicht. Kompliment, ich finde es Kompliment, wer hätte das als Kompliment? Das nervt mich, weil dann kommen Leute mit ihrer scheiss Intellektualität und kommen dann wirklich...
Ja, mehr, mehr Intellektualität. Weißt du, es gibt Leute, denen steht ihre Intellektualität einfach im Weg zu verstehen, worum es eigentlich geht. Die haben einfach ihre Intellektschablone und die drücken die aufs Thema drauf und sagen, es gibt doch ohnehin keine objektive Bedeutung von Sprache. Ja, darum ging es ja auch nicht. Und macht sie das wieder doof. Aber so, richtig, das ist genau so, also zum Beispiel, wenn jetzt zwei Leute auf einer Party diskutieren und sagen, ah, ich habe da letztens diese Frau getroffen und dann sagt der andere, ja war das ein Date und dann sagt der andere, ja ich weiss nicht, kann man das schon Date nennen, wir haben uns zufällig getroffen und dann sagt er, ja klar, das ist ein Date, wenn ihr, man diskutiert, was ist genau ein Date, ab wann ist etwas ein Date.
Niemand sagt, es gibt eine objektive Sprache, die hundertprozentig, sondern es gibt unterschiedliche Auslegungen eines Wortes und es macht Spaß, darüber zu diskutieren, genauso wie man darüber diskutieren kann, was eine Pizza Hawaii ist. So, das schon mal raus, weil das nervt mich dann, weil das damit nichts zu tun hat. Und das ist jemand, der einfach Diskussionen beendet, der kommt dann bei einer Party und sagt,, das ist doch kein Date, da muss man sich vorab reden und sagt, übrigens, es gibt überhaupt keine objektive Bedeutung der Sprache und es gibt überhaupt nicht sowas, es gibt nur intersubjektive Kommunikation und du denkst, ja, darum geht's aber nicht. Fakt, das nervt mich schon wieder. Ich verstehe das und es ist wirklich so ein Totschlag-Argument, aber auf der anderen Seite sei gesagt, sei froh, dass wir solche Nachrichten bekommen, weil es kann auch, also auf eine Art ist es auch ein Kompliment. Wenn man über Intellektuelle, denen der Intellekt im Wege steht, wie du halt gesagt hast, Nachrichten bekommt, finde ich immer noch besser, ich finde, das ist eine, weiss nicht, eine bessere Art der Kommentare, Kommentare als jetzt, weiß ich nicht. Als was, als Hass? Pure Korrektur. Ja, okay. Als flanke, blankes Besserwässertum oder, weiß ich nicht, dusseliger Zuspruch. Ich finde, auf eine Art ist das, ähm, weil dann legen sie eine andere Messlatte an. naja ich weiss es auch nicht. Ich war, ich habe jetzt eh Bock auf Fussball, ich bin mit dem Fussballthema drin. Ich liebe meinen Fussball und die EM hat mich im neues Rabbit Hole Wertes gedacht, dass es nochmal Fussball wird, reingeschubst. Und das ja... Was sagst du zum Elfer? War es ein Elfer oder nicht? Es war kein Elfer. Nee, aber dann habe ich nämlich, weiss ich, die fantastische Dokus, wo ich bislang keinen Bock drauf hatte. Und da habe ich dann irgendwie Lust drauf bekommen durch diese ganze EM-Zeit. Und zwar sind das die Dokus, die kann man auf Prime gucken, All or Nothing. Die Dokus über die sozusagen from the inside Fussballmannschaften verfolgen, beobachten, dabei bleiben. Man kommt an die Orte, wo man normalerweise nicht ist. Taktikbesprechungen, Teamsitzungen, Krisensitzungen und sowas. Und das gab es verschiedene Staffeln, gibt es ja jetzt schon. Und die erste, die ich geguckt habe, war über die deutsche Nationalmannschaft in Katar 2022. Ja,pannende Doku, weil ich denke ja, und ich glaube, das denkst du auch so als objektiver Beobachter, der jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel Stakes im ganzen Spiel hat, aber denkt, wahnsinnig viel Geld steht dahinter, Milliarden Euros, Riesenindustrie, ja irgendwie, das läuft wahnsinnig professionell. Die deutsche Nationalmannschaft fährt nach Katar, alles irre professionell. Und die Sitzungen sind gut vorbereitet, da haben die ja Teampsychologen, die gucken, wie kann man die Leute drauf vorbereiten. Wir hätten ja mal gesprochen, lustigerweise über Masturbation, sollten Fussballer masturbieren und dachten so vorm Spiel. Das war unser Kommentar zur EM, ja, vielleicht liegt es daran, dass sie nicht genug gewichst haben.
Richtig. Das war unser Kommentar damals, aber das nur am Rande. Ne, aber und da hatten wir ja beide gesagt, wahrscheinlich ist das Thema so, weil die so sehr ins Detail gehen und Testosteronspiegel, was auch immer. Und es ist nicht so, weil diese Doku war so entlarvend, wie fucking amateurhaft da alles läuft, weil also die haben einen, der kam sehr früh zu Wort, Team-Psychologen. Das fand ich schon mal spannend. Klar habe ich gedacht, natürlich haben sie das, da geht es ja viel um mentale Stärke und es ist ja kein Geheimnis, dass wenn Leute mental gut vorbereitet sind, sie wahrscheinlich die bessere EM-WM spielen und mehr aus ihren, weiss ich nicht, Automatismen, die sie eh angelernt haben, rausholen können. Aber was sie dann gemacht haben, um den Leuten zu zeigen, zusammen könnte stark sein, gibt alles und das war schon ein Meme-Thema, ich bin ein ein bisschen late to the party, aber ich fand es so fantastisch, habe mich kaputt gelacht vorm Fernseher. Sie haben eine Doku über Graugänse gezeigt. Die erfolgreichsten Tiere des Tierreichs, die gewinnen jedes Jahr. Das war kein Fussballmatch. Weil die nämlich in, wie alle Vögel ja auch, also die Zugvögel, in Formationen fliegen und sich so halt abschirmen und so eine Formation fliegen, dass sie gemeinsam länger fliegen können als alleine. Also sie sind zusammen stärker als die Individuen. Und das haben sie gezeigt, um den Fussballern zu zeigen, fuck yeah, gemeinsam können wir es schaffen. Ja, die Graugans sind. Und dann zeigen sie mit so einer bedeutungsschwangeren Musik da drunter gelegt, mit so einem Beamer aufgebaut. Das sah auch alles nicht professionell aus. Jemand schaltet an seinem Handy oder Laptop, so HDMI angeschlossen, die Kabel hängen da von der Wand, diese Graugans-Doku. Und dann gucken da die Fussballer und du siehst in deren Gesichtern, dass sie das ultra peinlich finden und die müssen sich so ein Lachen unterdrücken. Und das ist so krass, wie Hansi Flick, so hieß der Trainer, der damals die Deutschlandseleiter Mannschaft trainiert hat, gar keine Ebene mit denen hat. Ich fand das so bezeichnend, wie irre das war. Ja, oder es ist halt die Strategie, dass die Spieler sich gegen den Trainer verbünden und dann so eine Kameradschaft finden. Ist ja vielleicht so dieser Vertretungslehrereffekt, dass wenn du dich als Trottel darstellst, rücken die näher zusammen, weil sie haben gemeinsam Feind. Ich glaube, so würde ich das als Trainer machen. Ich würde mich aktiv unbelebt machen, damit die zusammenrücken und gegen mich lästern und am Ende sagen, ja, dem zeigen wir es, wir können auch gewinnen, ohne dass er macht, was er will. Spannend, ja, irgendwie alles sehr bezeichnend. Und dann war halt die, das war ja diese WM in Katar, die ja auch in Deutschland viele boykottieren wollten. Und dann war eine Ansage ans Team auch, keiner in Deutschland drückt euch gerade die Daumen, die wollen die WM boykottieren, niemand steht hinter euch. Und ich dachte mir, ist das die beste, also ich verstehe schon, weil das kann ja den gleichen Effekt, den du gerade beschrieben hast, auslösen. Ja, ja. So, ah, wir gegen die alle, wir zeigen es denen. Ja, ja. Aber das macht doch Druck und ist unangenehm. Sollte man das nicht komplett weghalten? Schwer zu sagen, ich bin kein Teampsychologe, aber es kann natürlich auch sein, dass man sagt, weil es kann ja auch den Druck nehmen, so, weil ich finde, der Druck ist schon enorm auf diesen Leuten, weil es ist ja oft nur so drei Torchancen und einmal, die schießen ja teilweise wirklich weit, also ich habe ja keine Ahnung von Fußball, aber manchmal denke ich mir, die schießen schon wirklich weit am Tor vorbei, also wirklich, das ist bestimmt ultra schwer, aber ich als neutraler Beobachter. Das ist für dich weit am Tor vorbei? Wirklich so, alles über eine halbe Torlänge würde ich direkt aus dem Team schmeißen und mir denke, Kollege, so ein Fussballtor ist gross, also wenn du da mal drin stehst, das ist riesengroß. Aber ist denn hinter dem Tor noch so ein zweites Netz? Weil teilweise schießen die mit voller Wucht am Tor vorbei direkt ins Publikum, oder? Da ist oft noch ein Publikum. Es ist ja nicht einfach Kollateralschaden, dass da einfach pro Schuss drei Kiefer brechen. Ja, ja, da ist noch oft ein Netz dahinter, aber nicht in jedem Stadion, nicht in jedem Stadion. Aber ich glaube, hinter dem Tor hat das echt. Weil ich finde das schon, also ich finde das ein bisschen gefährlich, muss ich sagen. Ich habe da tatsächlich Wertschätzung bekommen, ich habe jetzt Zivi gemacht und da war ein Zivierzieher, der war irgendwie ein krasser Fussballer anscheinend so.
Und ich habe immer mit den Kindern Fussball gespielt und dann so nach Feierabend, die Kinder gehen rein, wenn den Bus abgeholt kam, der noch raus und meinte so, ja, wollen wir noch mal so ein bisschen kicken. So, weil ich halt gegen die Kinder, ohne jetzt irgendwie angeben zu wollen, aber so, aber ich habe die schon einfach lang gemacht. Also ich habe die wirklich lang gemacht. Doch, ich habe die auf den Rücken gelegt und ich habe die beackert. Also nein, ich habe die wirklich, also die waren komplett fertig am Ende. Also ich habe die wirklich herangenommen, ich habe die herangenommen, jeden einzelnen. So und deswegen hatte ich auch ein bisschen Selbstbewusstsein. Warum? Und ich glaube, das hat dann dieser Erzieher auch gemerkt, dass ich halt irgendwie auch mal gut, den ein oder anderen guten Schuss raushaue, in so ein Kindergesicht.
Und dann meinte er so, ja, geh ins Tor. Und dann hat der aufs Tor geschossen mit einer solchen, die ich wucht, die ich noch nie, die ich nicht mal für physikalisch möglich gehalten habe. Also ich stand im Tor und das war wirklich, ich konnte das gar nicht wahrnehmen.
Also ich habe den Ball gesehen, ich konnte abschätzen, wo im Tor er landet und dann er war im Tor und dann habe ich mich erst bewegen und ich stand wirklich da und dachte, das kann nicht wahr sein. Also das war so anders, als wenn irgendwann irgendwie mit Kumpels oder so man schiesst. Das war eine solche Wucht. So wie es mir beim Baseball auf der Shooting Range, diese Batting Range, die wir in New York mal besucht haben. Wo man eigentlich schlagen muss, bevor der Ball schon abgeworfen wird. Wie bei der Wii, ja auch letztlich. Oder war das die Wii? Ja, Wii Sports. Ja, genau. Auf höchste Schwierigkeit. Also das fand ich, weil, das fand ich irre hart, hat alles wehgetan, dann war ich auch so ein bisschen so weinerlich. Ich erinnere mich, ich erinnere mich gut. Weil dann ging das so durch den Schläger und er das gar nicht so, das war richtig unangenehm. Ja, ja. Und dann hat er gesagt, er ist auf 20 Prozent. Und hat er immer aus Spars so angemacht, diese Maschine, die so nach und nach diese Bälle ausspuckt. Und wir sind dann rausgegangen, weil die kam in so einem Karacho da rausgeflogen. Das ist unmenschlich. Es ist so krass, wie gut gute Sportler sind. Also was das für ein riesiger Unterschied ist. Das kann man nicht wahrnehmen. Das kann man nicht wahrnehmen. Und deswegen finde ich ja die Idee immer noch super, die das Podcast-Ufo-Olympia-Idee, immer einen Average-Dude, Averageben mitlaufen zu lassen als Referenz. Ich glaube, der Typ, der wer wie ich, der kann einfach gar nicht, der rafft den Ball gar nicht. Der Ball wird um ihn herum gepasst und der kann gar nicht versuchen, dem hinterher zu laufen. Mir reicht es schon, stellt hinter das normale Champions League Tor noch ein Tor, wo jemand versucht, den Ball, weil selbst der wäre ja noch… Genau, n nimmt das Netz raus, so dass es durch das erste Tor durchgeht und dann nochmal durch irgendwie das Tor gehen. Und der soll versuchen, das zu halten. Und der wird sich immer so wegdrehen. Und das war richtig uneingenehm, weil irgendwie, der hat mir halt wirklich so sieben Tore reingezimmert und ich habe mich nicht mal bewegt. Und dann haben wir auch gesagt, machen wir Feierabend so, weil der, der hat, der dachte auch so, ich würde zumindest eine Chance haben. Aber das war kein professioneller. Nein, kein professioneller, aber einfach jemand, halt ein erwachsener Mensch, der regelmässig oder im Verein halt spielt und der einfach, also, wenn ich mir noch vorstelle, das jetzt noch auf Profi-Ebene, wie man überhaupt Torwart sein kann und sagen, ah Wahnsinn, unglaublich.
Haben Torhüter Angst, hat so ein Manuel Neuer Angst, den Ball mal so richtig ins Gesicht zu bekommen?
Ich glaube, der freut sich das. Ich glaube, du musst echt, ich hatte im Sportunterricht immer Angst und ich habe, wie gesagt, einmal der größte Moment meiner Schulkarriere, als der beste Fussballer auf mich zukam, geschossen hat und ich habe mich aus Angst auf die Seite geworfen, mit den Händen vorm Gesicht.
Und genau da ist der Ball hingetroffen und ich habe den Ball gehalten und alle, what the fuck! Und es sah von außen wahrscheinlich wie eine Parade aus. Absolut, ja. Und es war einfach nur ein zusammenkauerndes in die Ecke werfen, wo ich dann aus Versehen gehalten habe. Aber ich glaube, das will man. Ich glaube, du musst auch als Torwart einfach mal so zehn, das ist so deine, herzlich willkommen, du bist der neue Torwart und jetzt darf jeder mal dir ins Gesicht schiessen, damit du einfach komplett desillusiniert bist.
Ja, ich fand's einfach witzig auch, war das nicht so, dass einer von den Security-Leuten auf so einen Fussballer draufgefallen ist und der dann vernetzt war? Ja, da gab's einen Slitzer am Ende, da gab's einen Slitzer bei so einem Spanien-Spiel und die wollen ja dann oft Selfies machen oder sowas und ein Ordner wollte den aufhalten und ist dabei ausgerutscht und hat so wirklich wie so eine Grätsche so einen ganz unbeteiligten anderen Spanier umgegrätscht. Aber kann der, also könnte der theoretisch eine gelbe Karte kriegen? Ja. Also auch wenn du nicht Teil der... Der kann vom Platz fliegen. Also wenn ich jetzt jemanden grätsche von den Fussballen, kriege ich eine gelbe Karte. Ich würde eine gelbe Karte geben. Vielleicht sogar glattrot. Da haben ja auch Leute eine gelbe Karte bekommen, die gar nicht mitgespielt haben. Richtig, genau. Das finde ich ja auch geil. Also ich finde das grossartig. Wenn du auf der Bank bist, kannst du auch... So, du bist jetzt leise, ja, du setzt dich jetzt hin, ja, so, gelb. Gelb. Und dann sofort stille. Ja, Trainer können auch natürlich vom Platz fliegen, dann müssen die sich auf die Tribüne setzen, das ist ja auch immer lustig. Ich mag das immer, wenn das passiert. Ich finde das großartig. Aber er ist natürlich blöd, ne, also dieser Ordner, wie geht der abends nach Hause? Sagte, ich habe jetzt hier so einen Profifussballer, dessen Beine allein schon irgendwie mit 50 Millionen versichert sind. Genau diese Beine habe ich zerschmettert, aus Versehen. Denkt er sich entweder, okay, ich bin eine Schande, ich lege meinen Job nieder, oder sagt er, ich könnte auch Verteidiger sein. Also den habe ich umgesendet. Warum nicht? Warum nicht? Aber das ist wirklich das, weil ich denke, das ist ja auch das Niveau, auf dem die spielen, ist ja irre. Aber das hat es noch nicht ins Trainerteam, zumindest 2022, geschafft. Und dann auch die Reden von dem waren auch alle scheisse, diese Pep-Torren. Ach, jetzt mach den nicht fertig hier, mach den nicht fertig. Du hast groll, dass das Team damals nicht weit gekommen ist. Nee, jetzt möchte ich mich da ins Gespräch bringen. Achso, du möchtest Trainer werden? Nee, aber so Redenschreiber oder sowas für Kabine.
Das Letzte, was du ja willst, ist, dass du dann Zettel rausholst mit einer Rede. Nee, die kann er ja auswendig lernen. Ich denke mir, gute Trainer haben doch auch gute Sprüche aufs Lager und sowas und Klopp. Naja, also das war jedenfalls alles ein bisschen wackelig und dann hat irgendwann ein Spieler einfach dann gesagt, kann ich? und hansi fliegt so der spieler einfach so aus dem bauch raus niklas füllkrug also aus dem
bauch aus dem er wurde der wurde wurde noch reingeholt weil einer verletzt ausgestiegen ist und einen tag vor der wm irgendwie anruf bekommen und war dann so ersatzspieler und ist dann so hat dann die mannschaft zusammengepeitscht hat dann eine rede aus dem aus dem bauchhaus gehalten und alle haben so gänsehaut bekommen und waren so, yeah, und dann haben sie das irgendwie noch gewonnen.
Es war jedenfalls erschreckend, wie am Ende des Tages, so professionell wie etwas ist, am Ende sind es halt einfach nur Menschen, die Graugans-Dokus zeigen und das für eine gute Idee halten.
Ich mag aber diesen Künstlertrainer total gern, der sagt, ihr müsst mehr wie Graugänse sein. Also ich würde auch gerne so eine Sketch-Reihe machen, Regisseure als Fussballtrainer, dass sie wirklich sagen, schiess nochmal aufs Tor, aber versuch dabei wirklich nochmal im Hinterkopf zu halten, dass du wirklich alles aufgegeben hast, um hier zu sein. Denk an deine Mutter, denk an deinen Bruder. Was hat genau mein Bruder damit zu tun, dass ich jetzt hier auf die ...
Dein Bruder, deine Mutter konnte nicht beim Geburtstag deines Bruders sein, weil sie für dich zum Turnier ins Ausland geflogen ist, um dich da zu unterstützen. Aber sie wollte bei mir sein, also bei ... Ja, aber sie konnte nicht bei ihrem Bruder sein, okay? Und nimm das mal mit für den nächsten Schuss. Okay, aber soll ich oben links ins Eck oder rechts ins Eck? Geh das nochmal im Kopf durch und sag wirklich, meine gesamte Familie hat sich aufgeopfert für diesen Schuss. Aber soll ich Coach, Coach, soll ich oben links? Wir machen noch eine, wir machen noch eine, und bitte. Also jetzt oben links rein oder unten rechts in die Ecke? Okay, Achtung. So, jetzt habe ich unten rechts rein getroffen. Cut, okay. Wie cut?
Die war schon ganz gut. Wir machen noch eine.
Mach mal eine komplett frei. Mach mal eine, wie du denkst.
Egal, wohin schießen.
Mach mal eine komplett, wie du willst.
Okay, einfach so.
Wir machen noch mal eine, eine komplett frei.
Alles klar, klar, Coach.
Zeig mir mal, wer du bist. Ich will diesen Schuss sehen und ich will dich in diesem Schuss sehen.
Ich bin der Flo.
Alles klar?
Hä, ich bin der Flo.
Und bitte!
Der war's. Cut, danke, wir haben's. Finn. Ja, genau das wünsche ich mir eigentlich auch. Und dann habe ich eine andere Doku geschaut, es hört nämlich nicht auf mit diesen All-or-Nothing-Dokus über Manchester City und da gab es dann, das erfolgt Manchester City durch die Saison, diese krasse Saison, die die hatten, ihr wisst es besser als wir, mit Pep Guardiola, dem Trainer, den du ja auch kennst als Münchner. Der Pepe, na was. Na weiss, das ist der Peppy. Das ist der Peppy. Der macht die Sachen, der stellt die Spieler auf. Die laufen links, die laufen rechts. Der lauft links um mich, weiss der gar nicht mehr, wo links und rechts ist, weiss der fast da links. Also der Peppy, der macht das super. Ja, der hat ja den Stammtisch ewig mitbekommen. Hast du alles mitbekommen, während du alleine am Nebentisch sass? Was sagt ihr? Kön Könnt ihr mal lauter sagen? Könnt ihr von Anfang an noch mal verpassen? Wen meint ihr? Ist die Bank, einfach die Bank für den Stammtisch. Und dann können die sich immer auswechseln lassen. Und wenn jemand krank ist, zum Beispiel zu viel getrunken hat, wirst du eingewechselt. Gab es denn schon mal die Situation, dass ein Spieler ausgewechselt wurde, aber sich einfach partout geweigert hat, den Platz zu verpassen. Ja, ich glaub schon.
Nee, nee, nee, das war, hast du eine Ahnung, wie nass der Rasen ist?
Das macht das mal besser, das war geil.
Ich hab ein gutes Gefühl gerade, ich hab ein gutes Gefühl gerade. Ich glaub, der Nächste, der Nächste wird's, der Nächste wird's.
Und Pep ist ein wahnsinnig charismatischer Typ, hält tolle Reden, den finde ich nämlich
richtig klasse als Trainer, der hat die Leute unter Kontrolle, du merkst, die haben
Gucken den an, der hat den Raum, die schauen den an, das ist super faszinierend für mich im Vergleich.
Und der heisst Peter?
Pep Guardiola.
Also wie heisst der?
Pepe, ich weiss es nicht.
Pepe?
Josep.
Jedenfalls kommt aus Barcelona, ich weiss nicht genau, was so ein richtiger Name ist, aber Guardiola.
Und der ist fantastisch, ist ein Taktik-Fuchs und der geht richtig ins Detail und das macht sehr viel Spaß, sich da so reinzunerden. Und der hat ja diesen starken spanischen Akzent mit sehr vielen Fehlern. Und dann ist das Spannende, weil ich habe es auch auf Englisch geguckt mit deutschen Untertiteln, ähm, nee, englischen Untertiteln. Ich habe es auf Englisch geguckt mit englischen Untertiteln. Aber er spricht Deutsch. Nee, er ist wie gesagt Spanier, der spricht auf Englisch. Ach so, ich dachte, er fängt sie bei, okay. Nee, nee, er hat mal trainiert. Aber er ist ein Spanier, spricht also bruchstückhaftes Englisch mit heavy Spanish accent. Die Doku hatte englische Untertitel. Und ich verstehe den auch nicht so gut. Die Dokumacher mit den Untertiteln haben den wohl auch nicht so gut verstanden. Und dann haben sie oft seine Sätze korrigiert, weil die machen ja grammatikalisch, die hören einfach auf. Ja, ja, ja. Wie willst du das halt kennzeichnen? Also haben sie aus jedem Satz den logischsten, richtigen englischen Satz gemacht.
Dadurch liest er sich aber, jetzt habe ich so gedacht, wenn es Leute das gucken, die nicht hören können zum Beispiel, nur lesen, wirkt er wie ein ganz anderer Mensch. Und es nimmt ihm so ein bisschen den Zauber. Ja. Weil da steht ja nicht with heavy Spanish accent, sondern da steht einfach normales Englisch, aber halt so einfache Sätze, weil die suchen dann, dann fehlt man Verb oder so, wenn er spricht. Und es klingt halt wie dieser Künstler, dieser charismatische Künstler, der irgendwie gut spricht. Und du hörst ja, es ist nicht seine erste Sprache. Aber die Untertitel transportieren das nicht. Da klingt er wie ein Kind. Da klingt er wie ein Muttersprachler Kind, was mit einfachen, fertigen Sätzen, richtigen Sätzen, aber mit sehr wenig Vokabular die Message rüberbringt. Und es ist so spannend für mich zu beobachten, dass es keiner nicht sein kann. Untertitel generell ist ein Riesenthema für mich, was mir irgendwie so ein bisschen Dorn im Auge ist. Es ist interessant, da ist auch dieses Trump-Thema, dass wenn du Trump-Untertitelst oder so, behältst du dann dieses Bruchstückhafte, der bringt ja kaum einen Satz zu Ende so bei oder versuchst du das Wald, wollte er wahrscheinlich sagen oder transkribiert? Im Drehbuch zum Beispiel, wenn jemand unterbrochen wird oder wenn jemand den Satz nicht zu Ende bringt, gibt es ja diese Spiegelstriche. Ja, ja. Also zwei Gedankenstriche im Sinne von, er hat sich selber oder wurde unterbrochen. Er hat sich selbst unterbrochen, finde ich gut. Aber jetzt gab es ja bei der EM, ich habe nur bruchstückhaft reingeschaut, da gab es ja auch Spieler bei den Niederländern zum Beispiel, die hießen dann irgendwie Nick de Vries oder so, ist ein Formel-1-Fahrer, aber die haben Nick und dann D und dann Vries, also die haben nochmal dieses Wort, so Ludwig van Beethoven. Angenommen, wie ist das denn, angenommen, der würde jetzt in der Spiegel-Doku auftauchen und man müsste den abkürzen, würde man dann sagen, Ludwig V? Also so, die Messi-Wohnung in Dortmund, der Star-Komponist soll sein ganzes Geld versoffen und verhurt haben, Spiegel TV passte ihn an dem Türrahmen ab. Ludwig V oder ist es Ludwig V B, Herr Ludwig V B, wie viele Gülden haben Sie dieses Jahr versoffen? Aber wie kürzt man das ab oder so bei Gerichtsverfahren oder so? Also wo du ja normalerweise, ich plädiere ja schon lange für den zweiten Buchstaben des Nachnamens, ich glaube, das geht mittlerweile. Ludwig BE ist okay. Ich glaube, wir müssen es im Datenschutz auch nicht übertreiben. Aber wie macht man das da? Wie ist es da? BVE?
Ich handel es da ganz klassisch mit der Abiturliste, die alphabetisch verliehen wird. Das Abiturzeugnis wird alphabetisch verliehen. Ah ja, ist Beethoven ganz oben oder wann Beethoven ganz unten? Stark. Wie hättest du es? Oben? Bei Beethoven Pfann. Ja. Nene, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, neosse. Es ist schwer, wie macht man die Reihenfolge, ne? Ja, ja, ja. Artikel immer nach hinten. Boah, es gibt diesen Kameramann in Deutschland mit dem geilsten ... Ich kann jetzt noch ein bisschen wegen Alexander Grosse noch ein bisschen was zur Phalanx-Theorie sagen. In der Zwischenzeit werden Stefan recherchiert. Nun, man muss sich natürlich den antiken Kampf in einer Phalanx-Formation vorstellen. Schild und lange Spieße, Speere, viele Glieder tief. Aber interessanterweise, was damals auch schon antike Militärstrategen herausgefunden haben, ist, dass sich tatsächlich die Kampfformation im Laufe einer Schlacht nach rechts verschiebt. Also die Soldaten wandern nach rechts. Immer nach rechts. Wenn man sich jetzt zwei dieser Schildwallblöcke vorstellt, die knallen aufeinander, die schaffeln nach rechts ein bisschen. Also dann drehen sie sich so ein wie so eine Zimtschnecke. Sie reiben so aneinander vorbei, die beiden Schildwecke, so ein bisschen nach rechts. Sie schiften alle so ein bisschen nach rechts. Warum? Warum? Weil man das Schild in der einen Hand hat, das Schwert in der anderen Hand und natürlich die Stärke aus dem linken Arm quasi. Wahrscheinlich drückt man ja, ich glaube, Kämpfe waren auch wahrscheinlich realistisch, recht unästhetisch. Ja, ja, nee, es ist das, du hast dein Schild in der linken Hand, das heisst, der Schild deines rechten Kameraden ist rechts von dir. Du drückst von dir und du versuchst immer noch ein bisschen in den Schild des Rechten von dir zu gehen, der auch und alle wollen mehr geschützt sein als durch ihren eigenen Schild, deswegen gehen sie nach rechts, deswegen shiftet die komplette Kampfreihe nach rechts, was damals den Strategen auch aufgefallen ist, weswegen die gesagt haben, ja irgendwann überlappen die sich ja so gegenseitig und damit ist die rechte Seite die stärkere weil die irgendwann überlappt und die linke Seite ist unterlegen also wo positioniere ich jetzt meine Elitekräfte sollen die links die Front halten gegen die Übermacht des Gegners oder sollen die rechts übernehmen und aufrollen komplett und du wärst der bessere Trainer als Hansi Flick weil du kannst besser reden und das Wichtigste du hast Ahnung von Also F Fussball geht auch darum, du musst eine Kugel hinter die Linien deines Gegners hinbringen. Du willst ja auch wahrscheinlich bei Kriegsstrategie die Reihen deines Gegners durchbrechen. Ähnliche Idee, ja. Ja, die Idee ist ja wahrscheinlich auch trotzdem, die Reihen zu durchbrechen, um quasi hinter die Linie zu kommen, weil dann hast du, weiss ich nicht, Stadtkern. Kriegst du zwei punkte genau krieg man drei punkte und dann ist auch gut das schicht im
schacht am feierabend und dann wird noch ein bier getrunken das ganz kurz zur verlangstheorie du hast deine recherche beendet genau es gibt nämlich den der beste nachname der bislang untergekommen ist er löst damit den torhüter der kölner haie für mich ab wie haben wir die Liste, die besten Nachnamen, die ich kenne. Ja, wie war der nochmal? Danny aus den Birken, stark, a, Danny, Danny ist gut, ja.
Wurde jetzt, also Danny aus den Birken, fand ich fantastisch, wurde jetzt abgelöst von einem deutschen Kameramann, Philipp Baben der Erde.
What?
Der Nachname ist Baben der Erde, b, a, b, e, n, der Erde.
Was ist das denn? Ja, ja. Baben der Erde? B-A-B-E-N der Erde.
Wie, was ist das denn?
Ja, ja.
Baben der Erde, BDE?
Boah, ist das stark.
Philipp, Baben der Erde.
Das ist grossartig.
Das ist fast zu Erdbeben so ein bisschen falsch gesprochen.
Aber jetzt habe ich, genau, es klingt so mächtig.
Aber ist es nicht Beben der Erde, sondern Baben der Erde? Baben der Erde.
Ja, ja, ja.
Also auch drei Wörter, ne, Baben der, aber jetzt habe ich gesagt, Nachnamen können auch so sein. Und du heisst Tietze? Du heisst Will. Was soll das denn sein? Das ist Schmidt, Tietz, oder Schulz, Baben der Erde. Ey, vor allem wirklich, wenn ihr Single seid, Kameramann ist ein guter Beruf, dieser Mann muss heiraten, dieser Mann, dieser Name muss konserviert werden irgendwie. Es braucht eine Stiftung, Konservierung, besonders edler Namen, dass die Leute, falls die irgendwie jetzt im Dating Game jetzt nicht so fit sind, es gibt ja auch Pickup-Artists, es gibt ja auch irgendwie Kurse, dass man da denen vielleicht so einen Kurs irgendwie finanziert, wo man einfach mal sagt, so Kieferanpassungen oder so, da gibt es ja
mittlerweile, kann man ja viel machen.
Ich bin jetzt nur so peripher
involviert in solche Geschichten, aber ich glaube,
da kriegt man heute eigentlich jeden unter die Haube,
will ich mal sagen.
Dass man sich da wirklich an die Rand zeigt, damit die nicht
verloren gehen.
Oder adoptieren. Man kann sich ja
adoptieren lassen und dann den Namen.
Ist wahrscheinlich leichter als heiraten, dass du
sagst, adoptier mich bitte.
Okay, passt, du hast ja gesagt.
Jetzt habe ich deinen Nachnamen, ciao.
Ist dann rechtlich binden?
Das reicht, ist rechtlich binden.
Ich finde aber auch, du hast eine Verantwortung als Eltern.
Also wenn du Baben der Erde heisst.
Geil. Also ich finde
Jessica
passt nicht so richtig. Nee, nee, das muss schon so ein wirklich Erasmus-Baben der Erde. Ich finde, Philipp ist so noch genau auf der Grenze. Philipp ist so auf der Grenze. Philipp, Vater von Alexander der Grosse übrigens. Das ist natürlich auch ein antiker Name, der da gut passt, der irgendwie eine gewisse Gravitas in sich hat. Ja, das stimmt schon. Alexander der Grosse war schwul. Sagt man. Habe ich neulich nämlich einen spannenden Artikel darüber gelesen, ob das wichtig ist.
Also eine Abhandlung.
Naja, du schreibst gerade einen Artikel darüber.
Es war ein Artikel, da wurde es dann ein geilen Meter. Es war eine wissenschaftliche Arbeit über das wissenschaftliche Arbeiten an der Sexualität Alexander des Grossen. Ja, okay. Dekliniert man das dann? Dreifache Genitiv, die verschieben sich immer nach rechts, die Genitive, immer ein Stück nach rechts pro Wort. Aber was ich spannend fand, also da hat jemand daran gearbeitet, ob es denn sinnvoll ist, daran zu arbeiten, und da habe ich gedacht, ach okay, das können auch wissenschaftliche Arbeiten sein. Moment mal, aber da hat dann wirklich ein Wissenschaftler gesagt, ich erforsche jetzt und der hat dann seinen Gaydar ausgepackt und es ist nochmal die ganzen Briefe von. Nee, Gaydar war Ebene 1. Ach, okay, also ein Historiker sagt, mein Gaydar blinkt ganz gräle. Alexander des Grossen auf. Und dann sagt der zweite Historiker, ist das überhaupt relevant, was du gemacht hast. Genau, wie relevant ist das dein Gelder anzustellen bei Leuten wie Alexander des Grossen? Okay. Spannend, also das fand ich interessant. Und wo ist dann nichts, wissenschaftliches Arbeiten so auch funktioniert? Wissenschaftliches Arbeiten ist, ich habe so viel Respekt. Du musst, weil vor allem... Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen verloren, also bei mir ist das Gegenteil ausgelöst. Ja gut, okay, das ist ja so eine destruktive Historie, sage ich auch oft. Genau. Dass du sagst so, du machst eigentlich nur andere Leute fertig. Aber wann ist der Punkt, du sagst, ich will ein Buch schreiben, jetzt halt wirklich dann nochmal über die Etrusker. Die Etrusker waren schwul. Etrusker, da waren wirklich die meisten. Also ich habe mir nochmal die Bildquellen angeguckt und also das kannst du mir doch nicht erzählen oder guck doch mal hin wie also wie
die sich bewegen also jetzt guck mal dir die hand an guck mal die hand ich meine der redet mit dem könig guck dir mal die hand also weil sie kommen zu mir ich habe sie aufgenommen als ich habe sie kennengelernt als studenten der viel erreichen will und so und ich bin ich habe ja gesagt ich bin gerne ihr doktorvater ja dankeschön ich glaube das ist nicht das richtige thema warum Naja, sie haben andere Schwerpunkte.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das...
Sollte man das untersuchen?
Nein, ich bin jetzt 24 Jahre alt. Ich glaube, ich bin bereit, über das Königreich der Etrusker, das über 260 Jahre spannende Königreich Etruskien, vollends, vollends wirklich zu schreiben. Okay, dann machen Sie das doch. Also komplett, wirklich so viele Generationen an Menschenleben,
da mache ich einfach mal ein Buch drüber. Super, okay.
Und die waren stockschwul, aber jeder einzelne.
Und da stellen sich natürlich gewisse... Aber das ist ein Kapitel des Buchs.
Oder wie heisst das? Haben Sie schon einen Titel für das Buch?
Die Etruska waren schwul.
Alle.
Untertitel? Ja. Alle? Untertitel alle alle alle fragezeichen unter untertitel alle punkt ausrufezeichen ja super die tusker waren schwul alle alle wo das wäre das istur, die im Titel ... Das finde ich die beste von den Buchliedern aller Zeiten.
Ihr seid schuld.
Wir sind schuld? Wir? Ihr seid schuld.
Das ist ein Dialog.
Wer ist diese Figur, mit der er redet? Ja, ja, genau.
Eigentlich die Überschrift ist eine Rede von einer einzelnen Person.
Hansi Flick, da kommt Füllkrug dazu zwischen und sagt, wer ist schuld? Ihr seid schuld. Eigentlich immer, wenn man noch so ins Publikum fragt. Deutschland schafft sich ab. Wirklich? Wirklich. Ja, wirklich. Schafft sich ab? Schafft sich ab, absolut. So muss es sein. Aber allein zu sagen, wann in deiner Karriere kommt der Punkt, wo du sagst, so, ich habe genug über Etrusker gelesen, jetzt schreibe ich das Buch.
Weil Leute werden ja ein Buch über Etrusker schreiben und zwei Wochen später schauen sie eine NTV-Doku, wo jemand sagt, der König Ramses von Etruskien hatte eine besondere Vorliebe für Streitwägen, weswegen er auch die grosse Schlacht von Kamaraena gewonnen hat. und du so, was, echt? Oh man! Und jetzt, ich habe mein buch schon geschrieben fuck das selbstbewusstsein überhaupt ich finde das noch krasser als bei serien oder filmen oder was auch
immer dass das muss dann ein buch zu schreiben finde ich irre das ist so ein riesiges thema so
schreibt doch so ein eine person in der gesch, wo ich denke, ein Menschenleben reicht, um ein anderes zu verstehen. Gewagte These, aber ich lasse ihn mal stehen. Wohingegen jetzt ein komplettes Weltreich, eine gesamte Kultur, das ist zu viel für mich. Das finde ich zu viel. Alles, was sie über Ägypten wissen mussten. Ägypten in fünf Minuten, antikes Ägypten für Dummies, das ist so, hey, das ist eine Menge. Ja, es gibt ja auch diese Philosophy for Dummies Bücher, diese kleinen gelben und sowas, die man dann immer so an Bahnhöfen sieht. Ja, also Nietzsche in fünf Minuten so. Da habe ich mich sehr geärgert während meines Philosophiestudiums, weil ich mir dachte, das ist keine echte Philosophie. Für jemanden, der fünf Minuten Philosophie studiert hat, wäre das eine gewaltige These, aber gut, das lassen wir auch mal so stehen. Ein Menschenleben reicht aus, um ein Menschenleben zu beschreiben. Ich glaube, ich wäre als Nietzsche auch sauer. Also stell dir mal vor, du gehst jetzt irgendwie in den lokalen Hugendubel, schaust dich da um und da steht, Stefan, Tietze für Eilige, Tietze in fünf Minuten. Würdest du nicht denken, wow, man kann mein Schaffen, mein Magnum Opus, mein Werk doch nie in fünf Minuten zusammenfassen. Wie soll das gehen? Du brauchst mindestens vierhundertsechzigminütige Podcastfolgen, um mein Leben komplett abzudenken. Ja, so ein Riesenbiografie-Klopper. Ich meine, liebe Grüße übrigens an den Biographen von Stefan Tietze, der wahrscheinlich in akribischer Quellenarbeit alle Folgen in doppelter Geschwindigkeit angehört hat, liebe Grüße. Frage, kann man die Wichtigkeit eines Menschen anhand der Dicke der Biographie erkennen? Ne, ich glaube, die Anzahl der Biografien, wie viele Biografien wurden geschrieben, darüber glaube ich. Und da ist Hitler auf ein, Sigmund Freud auf zwei und Heino auf drei tatsächlich. Ja, stimmt, ne? Also ein Buch kann ja jemand, der einfach nur versessen ist, von jemandem absolut obsessiv, fast stalkerhaft. Ja, vor allem ich finde gute Biografien ist kurz und knackig. Also wenn du ein Leben, also wirklich so 200 Seiten, dann muss auch durch sein. Ansonsten versabbelt man sich. Aber kann ich denn zu einem Verlag gehen und sagen, ey, habt ihr nicht Bock, eine Biografie über mich zu schreiben? Oh, das fand ich übrigens lustig, eine Biografie über soie, aber genau in diesem Wortlaut. Es war das Haus, in dem er später seinen Podcast aufzeichnen sollte. Aber genau, in diesem Duktus, wo man so etwas sagt, das war das Haus, in dem er später seinen Muttertod auffinden würde. Dieser Sprech über jemanden ganz und gar normales. Ja, wirklich, ja. So ein Influencer, der irgendwie so 80 Follower erreicht hat und der es immer wollte, aber nicht geschafft hat. Oder einfach so ein, weiss ich nicht, so ein Geometrie, ne, Geographie, Jesus, Studenten. Boah, ich hab grad richtig so Gehirnprobleme.
Schlaganfall. Ich hab grad richtig, boah, ich bei dem Wetter krieg ich ja wieder richtig Schlaganfall.
Also heutzutage, wo mir keine Wörter einfallen.
Jetzt mal, jetzt mal unter uns. Also ich finde, ist es eitel, wenn man sich selber um seinen Nachlass kümmert?
Ja, ja, sehr eitel.
Okay, dann, okay, bevor du antwortest.
Ja.
Angenommen, ich hol mir jetzt so eine Bronze Plakette. So, Geburtshaus Florentin Will. Und. Während du noch drin lebst. Du klebst auf deine Wohnung unten Geburts. Hier hat Florentin Will gelebt. Genau. Und dann so, aber noch aus. Zweitens nach 18 bis und dann ist es freigelassen. Freigelassen, weil du nicht weisst, wann du aussiehst. Aber wie ist es bei Wohnungen? Wo hängt man da die Bronze Plakette hin? Unten an die Klingen oder an vor die Wohnungen? Wollen wir das als Kunstobjekt machen? Wir lassen uns das wirklich tun. Wir haben ja unser Podcaststudio in dieser kalten Anwaltskanzlei. Ja, kalten kapitalistischen Peitschanstalt, wo wir die Berater ansteigen. Ja, genau. Wollen wir da unten, das Gebäude von außen sieht zunächst recht imposant aus. Ja. Kommt man rein und merkt, ist es nicht, da ist Fassade. Ja, ja. Aber außen ist ganz cool. Wollen wir da so eine grosse Bronzenplakette, die so aussieht wie so Wahnmal? Ja, wie so Goethe, wie so Goethes hat hier gewirkt oder so. Genau, hier wurde von dem, der deutsche Podcast das Podcast-Ufo aufgezeichnet. Fände ich gut, ja. So eine Bronzenplakette, was kostet das? Für einen Fuffi. Einen Fuffi, da konntest du gut hin. Bronze ist Bissmetall. Da gehst du zu einem Bronzeschmelzer oder so. Gibt doch quasi mittlerweile in jeder grösseren Stadt, gibt es doch einen Bronzeschmelzer, oder? Einen Broncier so, dann gehst du hin und machst eine Plakette so ins Geburtshaus oder so an die eigene Schule, dachte ich auch. Würde das wirklich entfernt werden? Also angenommen, in der Nacht-und-Nebel-Aktion gehe ich jetzt zu meiner Schule und mache da so eine Bronzeplakette hin. Die meisten würden doch denken, ah okay, das hat da jemand anders aufgehängt oder so, aber es würde da halt wahrscheinlich lange hängen und irgendwann ist es ja etabliert. Du nimmst ja nicht nach 20 Jahren die Bronzeplakette ab, sondern irgendwann ist sie etabliert und du denkst, ich kann jetzt nicht einfach diese Plakette abmachen. Es gibt ja, ja, es ist ja immer so Leute, die dann ihren ersten Wikipedia-Artikel dann irgendwie selber schreibenas. Ja. Ist immer so unangenehm, aber meiner Erfahrung nach, dieses Ellenbogenverhalten, habe ich beobachtet, setzt sich durch. Und da habe ich auch oft so gedacht, ah, fuck, warum, aber ich weiß nicht, mir ist das immer zu unangenehm oder so gewesen. Aber ich glaube, manchmal setzen sich solche Leute durch. Und ich glaube, beziehungsweise habe die Angst, dass es auch in diesem Kosmos funktionieren würde. Absolut, absolut. Okay, das machen wir jetzt. Ich würde auch gerne eine Bronzemedaille für deine, so eine Plakette für deine Schule machen. Für deine Schule? Das traue ich mich nicht. Doch, klar. Da kann man dann wirklich die Jahreszahlen auch hinmachen und dann muss das halt nur jemand installieren. Und ich will so dein Profil, also wie so diese Schattenwälder und dann vielleicht so das motto auf lateinisch eramus hilarius oder irgendwie sowas das florentinville institut e.v sponsert genau irgendwie sowas in der richtung die florentinville stiftung oder irgendwie sowas in der richtung e.v das also falls ihr bronze schmelzer seid meldet euch mal dass wir das h allem wie befestigt man die, wie befestigt man die an der Wand? Ich habe einen Schmied kennengelernt. Schmied. Wir haben auch Schmiede. Fand ich sofort super cool. Was schmiedet er denn so? Ja, Schwerter. Gatter? Rüstungen und Schwerter. Ja, ich glaube tatsächlich manchmal noch für so Liebhaber. Und sonst wird viel geschlossert. Weil ich dann sag halt, dass du Schlosser bist, aber gut. Vielen, vielen Dank an euch fürs Zuhören wieder mal. Hätte ich ja nicht gedacht, dass wir da zusammenkommen. Es war eine Woche. Lang ist es her gewesen. Genießt das Wochenende. Ja. Dieses oder das nächste. Genießt eure Wochenenden und rackert euch durch die Wochen. Augen zu und durch, unter der Woche, am Wochenende
Augen auf.
Augen auf, lebt das Leben. Haut rein, macht's gut, wir heben ab, bis zu den Heben ab, hab er was Papagschluss.